has brought down the wall all the most
of Westeros on the other hand has agreed
to unite and center forces snort to
stand a chance against the only enemy
that matters let's start with first
prediction which is John and Daenerys
having a baby in the season 7 finale we
finally sold it to hook up while brains
voice or was explaining that they are in
fact related
it's me highlighted numerous times
during the season that Daenerys believes
she can no longer have children because
of a prophecy that was told to her by me
Remus door the prophecies when the Sun
rises in the West and sets in the East
when the Seas go dry and the mountains
blow in the wind like leaves when your
womb quickens again and you bear a
living child then he will return and not
before even though the nearest does
believe in this prophecy as Jon Snow
pointed out himself it may not be
entirely true additionally so many
people were talking about then his
ability of having children in so many
scenes that it seems like Jon and
Daenerys having a baby's not even
questionable but was rather foreshadowed
Tyrion talked to Danny about her plan
for succession Danny talked with Jon how
her dragons are the only children she'll
ever have and even Jorah talked to John
about his future child just as Jon Snow
stated it's highly possible that the
witch was not being honest with Dany
which along with all those foreshadows
might mean that the season finale brings
more surprising than we hoped for the
only problem with Dany getting pregnant
is another theory that has been floating
around for quite some time
if the nares truly got pregnant cause
she died in childbirth we know that her
mother died giving birth to her John's
mother also died giving birth to him
which puts the nares in pretty dangerous
situation let's continue with a
prediction that will almost surely come
true which is a huge fight between
Daenerys is remaining dragons in the
night Kings reanimated dragon once the
supreme leader of the White Walkers
placed his hand on missourians corpse
and basically raised him from the death
to act as his minion it became quite
certain that the final season will
contain some epic fights between the
dragons this will most probably
eventually resolve with the final death
of bazarian
which might have been foreshadowed back
in the first season let's firstly say
that the night King reanimated the
corpse of the Fallen Azarian which makes
the ice dragon a wight that can be
destroyed by either dragon glass or more
importantly for this theory by fire let
me also remind you that vissarion is
named after Daenerys his brother Viserys
and jorgen on the other hand is named
after Dana's late husband
Khal Drogo back in the first season
vizier Stretton Daenerys
which resulted with Drogo killing him by
dumping molten gold onto his head it's
quite popular theory the dragon named
that his ears will get his own version
of the golden crown in the last season
by the dragon named after Drogo let's
move on another prediction which has
actually been confirmed if the golden
company's survival on Westeros and their
conquest over it in the season finale
Cersei revealed to Jaime that younger
age I only pretended to be heading back
to Pyke out of fear when he has actually
sailed to Essos to hurt the golden
company and to bring them with his iron
fleet to Westeros to serve under serves
his commands this is not coming as a
huge surprise since in the fourth
episode of the season Cersei revealed
her intentions to take out a new loan
from the iron bank to hurt the golden
company to expand her armies this
elsword company is one of the largest
and most skilled mercenary organizations
there is consisting of 20,000 infantry
cavalry and more elephants with their
help sir still take the advantage of the
war between the living and the dead and
will most certainly retrieve some things
that in her opinion belong to her those
things that Cersei has also revealed
herself include the lands that are
currently taken away from her basically
by the living are fighting the dead
Cersei will try to as she calls it
retrieve kingdoms that belong to her
with the mercenary organization with
arrival the golden company there comes
another prediction which is the return
of Darian hearts several months ago I
brought you a theory in which dari will
reappear in the last season as either
than his Savior or than his enemy the
nears his last command to Daario and his
cell cert company was to enforce the
Queen's peace in the bay of dragons for
a few months until people choose their
rulers the second son's are known for
their loyalty and once they accept a
contract from one side of a conflict
they cannot break it and switch to the
other side since they would be seen as
unreliable and no one would hire them
again
it's almost safe to say that Daario beta
and his commands but what takes place
after death Daario fulfilled an his
orders and is now free from any contract
which makes a certain possibility that
he and his company will be hard to
support sources campaign over Westeros
another prediction that will most
certainly come true is John and the
nearest learning the truth about John's
lineage the season 7 finale confirmed
that John is not the bastard but rather
a trueborn son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark whose name is Aegon
Targaryen he is the true heir to the urn
and more importantly his the nurses
nephew John and Danny are heading to
Winterfell verse Amal and brain are
waiting for John to finally reveal him
the truth
it said to say that John will finally
reunite with Brandon Arya but he will
also find out the truth John and the
near soul without a doubt learn of their
family ties in the season finale but a
bit too late for quite some time fans
have been wondering which house will
generally present ones bran and Sam
revealed to him his true parentage this
question might have been answered by
John himself in the season finale while
having a conversation with Ian Gerrie
marked that even though thien's real
father was Balin Ned was more of a
father to him than Balin ever was John
said you don't need to choose your
agreed jury and you're a stark this
pretty much explains that John will
accept the fact that he is a Targaryen
but he will always be a stark as well
the king in the North might have bent
the knee to the dragon queen but once
those two learned the truth the near
sumo spur will be the one to support
John's claim to the Iron Throne next and
by far one of the best predictions
you'll have a chance to hear include
Circe's death Clegane Bo and
reappearance of jaqen H'ghar
the season 7 finale provided as many
reunions but none of them was an
interesting as a reunion that occurred
between kill game brothers a long
anticipated duel between the mountain
and the hound often referred to by fans
as cleganebowl has seemingly been set
for the final season in this theory a
game ball will take place a few moments
after the death of Cersei Lannister upon
realizing that they invested in wrong
ruler as Cersei might cause the fall of
Estoril since she's not supporting the
living side the iron bank would hire the
faceless man to put an end to search his
madness this is when Jackie not sneak
into Winterfell disguised as Norton ER
and would reunite with Arya Jackie would
then say to Aria that the many-faced God
requires another death
are you shocked and surprised would most
likely say that she is not no one but
rather Arya Stark of Winterfell pointing
out that she is not assassin and does
not play to obey any order nor to kill
anyone for the many-faced God
Jackie who then revealed the name of a
person whose death is required in the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms Cersei
Lannister who betrayed the living side
and is conquering the Seven Kingdoms
while the Great War rages are a stark
already wanted to head to the capital
and execute Cersei Lannister in the very
beginning of the season 7 which means
that she would most likely say
for in order not only to cross so
possibly the biggest name on her list
but also to kill the only person who
betrayed the living side senator Colgan
who will in the very first episode of
the final season arrived at Winterfell
with everyone else who decide to help
arias since with the mountain on her a
aura will not be able to kill Cersei or
on the other hands to arrive upon
killing Cersei when they sneak into the
red keep the two would go straight into
search his chambers area varying Qyburn
space would kill Cersei and just from
the mountain would jog his sword to kill
her for shadow clue gamble would take
place the count would fulfill his
promise that he gave to the mountain in
the season 7 finale it's not habitants
for your brother you know who's coming
for you you've always known let's
continue with the prediction regarding
the Greyjoy's yars intention to become
the queen of the Aran Islands was sang
by her uncle yearn Yara was last seen
tied to your own horse and being dragged
through the streets of King's Landing
all the way to the red keep upon finding
out from neuron that Yara still alive
theone rallied the remaining Ironborn
left in Dragonstone and formed a rescue
party so he could at least try to save
Yara but will feel managed to even come
close to Yara and if he does will he
find her alive or rather her corpse
remains unknown taking into account that
urine is sailing to Essos with his
entire iron fleet to bring the golden
company to Cersei Theon might manage to
save Yara if she remained imprisoned on
the Aran Islands
the next prediction is the return of the
death of Melisandre earlier in the
season 7 Melisandre inverse had an
interesting meeting
Melisandre revealed that she was just
about to depart for role antis but also
stated that she must return to Westeros
once more to face her end just like
we're still faced it soon let me now
introduce with a prediction regarding
both her reappearance and her death
let's start with the last sentence
Melisandre said to John you know the
Great War is still to come you know the
army of the Dead will be upon us soon
and you know I can help you in that war
once no Sandra returns to Westeros she
most certainly will not remain south but
will go northward the great war between
the living and the dead is taking place
taking into consideration of fact that
no sandrich has been exiled from the
north massager might reappear at
Winterfell in her true form well Sancho
take off her necklace along with her
Beria Newt with it and would once again
reveal her true form which is a frail
old woman who is approximately four
hundred years old
during her true form would return to
Winterfell since no one has ever seen
her true form no one actually knows how
she really looks like back in the third
season Alessandra prophesy to Aria that
they will meet again one day which might
go in favor to this prediction regarding
Melisandre three appearance there are a
couple of possibilities regarding mil
Sanchez death such as Melisandre having
to reveal who she actually is to Jon
Snow in order to convince him into her
new prophecies which would lead to her
death
since Jon promised her that if she is to
return to the north he will have her
hanged as a murderer
another possibility is a prophesied
meeting between Melisandre herself and
Arya which might lead to Mary Sanchez
death
we know that Arya is dedicated on
decreasing the names in her kill list
and you also know that no Sandra's name
is on that list considering all those
facts are you killing Melisandre most
certainly doesn't seem to be out of the
realm of possibilities